question to you is if marriage is a bad  idea for men what do you tell the most  men who are going to have children what  should they do I don't give  a given your Channel's advice  say I'm having a conversation I know but  I'm saying that I'm not an advice  Channel I don't advise men on how to  live their lives what I'm saying is you  should be aware of the laws today and  and make a decision accordingly and I  think a lot of times like when the red  pill will say this law that law like  girls are like this this and this it's  they're just warning you so and you can  do what you want with the information so  I love it so I'm saying it depends on  the guy